a definition of the amateur
the amateur is young and dumb he's
innocent
he's good-hearted he's well-intentioned
the amateur is brave
he's inventive and resourceful he's
willing to take a chance like luke
skywalker
the amateur harbors noble aspirations he
has dreams
he seeks liberation and enlightenment
and he's willing he hopes
to pay the price the amateur is not evil
or crazy
he's not deluded he's not demented the
amateur is trying to learn
the amateur is you and me what exactly
is an amateur
how does an amateur view himself and the
world
what qualities characterize the amateur
fear is the primary color of the
amateur's interior world
fear of failure fear of success fear of
looking foolish
fear of underachieving and fear of
overachieving fear of poverty fear of
loneliness
fear of death but mostly what we all
fear as amateurs
is being excluded from the tribe i.e the
gang
the posse mother and father family
nation race religion
the amateur fears that if he turns pro
and lives out his calling
he will have to live up to who he really
is and what he is truly capable of
the amateur is terrified that if the
tribe should discover who he
really is he will be kicked out into the
cold to die
the professional by the way is just as
terrified as the amateur
in fact the professional may be more
terrified because she is more acutely
conscious of herself
and of her interior universe the
difference lies in the way the
professional acts
in the face of fear
the amateur identifies with his own ego
he believes he is himself that's why
he's terrified the amateur is a
narcissist
he views the world hierarchically he
continuously rates himself in relation
to others
becoming self-inflated if his fortunes
rise
and desperately anxious if his star
should fall
the amateur sees himself as the hero not
only of his own movie
but of the movies of others he insists
in his own mind if nowhere else
that others share this view the amateur
competes with others
and believes that he cannot rise unless
a competitor
falls if he had the power
the amateur would eat the world even
knowing that to do so
would mean his own extinction
though the amateur's identity is seated
in his own ego
that ego is so weak that it cannot
define itself based on its own
self-evaluation
the amateur allows his worth and
identity to be defined by others
the amateur craves third-party
validation
the amateur is tyrannized by his
imagined conception
of what is expected of him he is
imprisoned
by what he believes he ought to think
how he ought to look
what he ought to do and who he ought to
be
paradoxically the amateur's
self-inflation prevents him from acting
he takes himself and the consequences of
his actions so seriously
that he paralyzes himself the amateur
fears
above all else becoming and being seen
and judged as himself
becoming himself means being different
from others
and thus possibly violating the
expectations of the tribe
without whose acceptance and approval he
believes he cannot survive
by these means the amateur remains
inauthentic
he remains someone other than who he
really
is the amateur has a long list of fears
near the top are two solitude
and silence the amateur fears solitude
and silence
because she needs to avoid at all costs
the voice inside her head
that would point her toward her calling
and her destiny
so she seeks distraction the amateur
prizes shallowness
and shuns depth the culture of twitter
and facebook
is paradise for the amateur
there was a popular bumper sticker a few
years ago
too much ain't enough too much in enough
and too soon is too late the amateur
the addict and the obsessive all want
what they want
now the corollary is that when they get
it
it doesn't work the restlessness doesn't
abate
the pain doesn't go away the fear comes
back
as soon as the buzz wears off
because the amateur is so powerfully
identified with herself
she finds it extremely difficult to view
the world through the eyes of others
the amateur is often unkind or
insensitive to others
but she saves her most exquisite cruelty
for herself
the amateur's fear eclipses her
compassion for others
and for herself
in his heart the amateur knows he's
hiding he knows he was meant for better
things he knows he has turned away from
his higher nature
if the amateur had empathy for himself
he could look in the mirror
and not hate what he sees achieving this
compassion
is the first powerful step toward moving
from being an amateur
to being a pro
the amateur believes that before she can
act
she must receive permission from some
omnipotent other
a lover or spouse a parent a boss a
figure of authority
the amateur sits on a stool like lana
turner at schwab's
waiting to be discovered
the amateur and the addict focus
exclusively on the product
and the payoff their concern is what's
in it for them
and how soon and how cheaply they can
get it
consumer culture is designed to exploit
the amateur
if you don't believe me watch 10 minutes
of tv or scroll through any magazine or
online shopping site
my beef with american culture is that
almost every aspect
including the deliberations of the
legislature and the judiciary
has been debased to pander to the
culture of amateurism
the promise that our products and
politicians proffer
is the promise one might make to an
infant or an addict
i will get you what you want and it will
cost you nothing
because the amateur owns nothing of
spirit in the present
she either looks forward to a hopeful
future or backward to an idyllic past
but the past evoked by the amateur is
make-believe it never
existed it's a highlight reel that she
edited together
from events that almost took place or
should have occurred
in a way the amateur's reimagined past
is worse when it's true
because then it's really gone the payoff
of living in the past or the future
is you never have to do your work in the
present
two hollywood producers were talking
i've got good news said one and i've got
bad news
give me the good news remember that
mansion we were trying to rent for the
big party scene
but we couldn't get because it cost
fifty thousand dollars for the night
well i just talked to the guy and he'll
give it to us for ten thousand dollars
what's the bad news he wants a hundred
bucks up front
the sure sign of an amateur is that he
has a million plans
and they all start tomorrow
have you ever followed a guru or a
mentor
i have i've given my power away to
lovers and spouses
i've sat by the phone i've waited for
permission
i've turned in work and awaited
trembling the judgment of others
i've given away my power subtly with a
glance that was perceptible to no one
and i've given away overtly and
shamelessly for all the world to see
exile failure and banishment can be good
things sometimes
because they force us to act from our
own center and not from someone else's
i applaud your story of how you hit
bottom
because at the bottom there's no one
there but yourself
the force that can save the amateur is
awareness
particularly self-awareness but the
amateur understands however dimly
that if she truly achieved this
knowledge she would be compelled to act
upon it
to act upon this self-awareness would
mean defining herself
i.e differentiating herself from the
tribe
and thus making herself vulnerable to
rejection
expulsion and all the other fears that
self-definition elicits
fear of self-definition is what keeps an
amateur and amateur and what keeps an
addict an addict
the amateur dreads becoming who she
really is because she fears that this
new person will be judged by others
as different the tribe will declare us
weird or queer or crazy the tribe will
reject us
here's the truth the tribe doesn't give
a [ __ ] there is no tribe
that gang or posse that we imagine is
sustaining us by the bonds we share
is in fact a conglomeration of
individuals who are just as [ __ ] up as
we are
and just as terrified each individual is
so caught up in his own [ __ ]
that he doesn't have two seconds to
worry about yours or mine
or to reject or diminish us because of
it
when we truly understand that the tribe
doesn't give a [ __ ]
we're free there is no tribe and there
never was
our lives are entirely up to us